well let's talk to southern and doom a
he's a resident fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute and has written on
Modi's government he joins us via Skype
from Washington DC Narendra Modi has
defended the bill but critics say look
it undermines India's secular
Constitution just how divisive is this
bill this is the single most divisive
thing that Narendra Modi has done since
he first came to power in 2014 it has
polarized the country not merely in
terms of Hindus and Muslims so that's of
course of course is part of it but I
think more importantly between those
Indians of all faiths including many
Hindus who see this as a challenge to
India's secular foundations and BJP
supporters who see this as a great
humanitarian gesture to religious
minorities in those three countries
Pakistan Afghanistan and Bangladesh and
southern and many people say the bill
allows Modi to draw attention away from
domestic issues like the worst in
economy unemployment the crisis in the
farming community do you think he's
deflecting attention from his own
domestic political issues no I think it
does allow him to deflect attention but
I don't think that you know any
government would do something this major
with such sort of you know serious both
symbolic and real consequences for the
trajectory of the country without this
really matter to them um the fact is
that they care about the cultural agenda
the fact is that they have come back to
power earlier this year with an enhanced
majority and they see that as a green
light to implement some of these
policies that they would have wanted to
implement earlier but were not able to
and Modi's been holding his own rallies
in New Delhi and he's blamed the
opposition for the protests accusing
them of spreading lies and rumors so
what are the opposition been saying well
you know the opposition has obviously
sort of you know taken to this they have
you know they have hit back at Modi and
pointed out that you know he has sort of
for instance he has claimed that there
is no plan to put in place
so register up citizen which would be a
kind of big list with you know
everybody's name on it and if you're not
on the list or you can't prove that you
were sort of you have the right kind of
documentation people fear that those
people would be denied citizenship so he
claimed that there was no such plan but
that's actually you know ludicrous
because his own home minister has
repeatedly said that that is precisely
their plan and he said this on the floor
of Parliament so the opposition is sort
of you know they're you know they're
feeling a little sort of you know when
did their tales but I think what's more
important is more these own comments it
does not look like he is backing down it
looks like he is trying to wrap some of
his own supporters southern are just a
final thought from you I mean how do you
gauge the international response to the
deadly protest we've seen so far against
the bill because currently it seems
quite muted I mean does the
international community care about this
just depends on which part you look at
right if you're looking at it in terms
of something the UN has spoken up the
members of the House of Representatives
in the u.s. have spoken up there has
been extensive international media
coverage I wrote a column in The Wall
Street Journal several others have
written about this so I think the
international community is certainly
concerned it's true that government
reactions have been muted but that's not
the same as saying that the
international community in general has
given India free pass on the contrary I
think this has been the worst two weeks
for the Modi government in terms of
international media coverage since they
took office 7 on 2 May thank you very
much indeed for talking to Al Jazeera
thanks for having me